[musique]
le premier est
montrer
Caucasiens ce que la Russie fait ici
crime que l'agression contre l'ukraine
elle est totalement injustifiée
la seconde est d'effacer le nom
les Tchétchènes qui essaient
dénigrer et la russie
[musique]
Je serai capturé aujourd'hui si Ukrainien
le soldat peut toujours m'échanger personne
m'a annulé immédiatement dans les premières heures
ils vont commencer à me torturer
Je serai montré à la télévision et
donc je n'ai pas de recul
[musique]
sûr si toutes les nations qui étaient
tous les droits sont violés
Empire russe s'ils s'unissent
il y a une vraie chance de casser
l'épine dorsale de ce violeur malveillant de Poutine
Et
éliminer les combattants de la surface de la terre
cet empire et que tous les peuples
se sentait libre et vivait librement
[musique]
filtrer
elle vous tend les enfants pour tel et nouveau
uniforme comme